the drone strike hit Iran's most
powerful general as he left Baghdad
Airport by car a splash of violence with
lasting consequences it's the most
aggressive action by the United States
in this region since the Iraq war
[Music]
Washington hopes the killing of Major
General Qasem Soleimani is bodacious
enough to turn Tehran away from conflict
but the opposite could well happen we
don't stick war with Iran but we at the
same time we're not going to stand by
and watch the Iranians escalate and
continue to put American lives at risk
without responding in a way that
disrupts defends deters and creates an
opportunity to de-escalate the situation
the overwhelming response from Iran is
grief fury and a desire for revenge but
first the country will hold three days
of national mourning America's action
without any doubt is an act of state
terrorism the pure and holy blood of
Qasem Soleimani will definitely make the
tree of resistance more robust and make
Iranian people more United a veteran of
Iran's war with Iraq the young soleimani
worked his way up through the ranks of
the Revolutionary Guard to head its
elite he then helped to reset the
balance of power in the region through
proxy militias in Iraq militiamen he
supported killed hundreds of British and
US troops following the 2003 invasion in
Syria he helped President Assad beat
back a bloody uprising as de facto
spymaster soldier and diplomat in chief
he would even go to Iran's arch enemy
I'm telling you mr. Trump the gambler I
am telling you no way you are not
thinking of we are near you places you
cannot imagine we are next to you maybe
he didn't count on being part of that
gamble this Revolutionary Guard was
moved to tears on national television at
the loss President Donald Trump who
authorized the drone strike said the
general had it coming
Qasem Soleimani has killed or badly
wounded thousands of Americans over an
extended period of time and was plotting
to kill many more but got caught his
death followed the storming of the US
Embassy in Baghdad by iranian-backed
militias Britain's now urging all sides
to de-escalate the Foreign Secretary
says further conflict is in none of our
interests for officials here at the
Foreign Office they're anxious to keep
alive the Iran nuclear deal that the
United States has rejected but if
hostilities worsen between the two sides
Britain will almost certainly side with
America its closest strategic ally this
former military end way to the Middle
East says it's a dangerous time I really
do think we need to all hold our breath
and slightly watch how violently Iran
wishes to respond to this you know how
much it feels its own its own
credibility's under under attack now
Iraq has a front row seat one of its
paramilitary Chiefs was also killed in
this drone strike it makes Baghdad
perhaps the most volatile flashpoint in
this crisis there behind Sky News